دجاج بيتي برنامج الذكاء الاصطناعي الذي
اصبح حديثا العالم لقدرته الفائقه على
كتابه النصوص وحل شفره البرمجه وحتى تاليف
النكات والسيناريوهات الافلام القصيره
البرنامج الذي لا يزال تحت التجربه خلق
حاله من الجدل الواسع في مدارس وجامعه
العالم ما بين تقييده او الاستفاده منه هو
عدو جديد للمحاضرين والمعلمين الطلاب
يعتمدون على روبوت الدردشه الذكي لكتابه
مقالات واعداد الابحاث في ثواني المعدوده
لكن اصوات اخرى
بنتائج عكسيه على العموم بسبب هذا الجدل
خرجت خدمه وهي مخصصه للمعلمين وتتمكن من
تحديدا نصوص التي تم تنفيذها بالذكاء
الاصطناعي رغم ذلك بدات طلاب في مشاركته
على مواقع التواصل مزيد معك نفس
ثماني جامعات استراليه اعلنت تعديل
اختباراتها مصنفه استخدام الطلاب للذكاء
الاصطناعي في خانه الغش المدارس العامه في
نيويورك قررت تقييد الوصول الى تشات جي بي
تي على شبكاتها بحجه ان الاداه لا تساعد
في تطوير التفكير النقدي ومهارات حل
المشكلات افكار وهي منصه حكوميه مسؤوله عن
وضع التقيمات والاختبارات في انجلترا
تناقش حاليا وضع ارشادات اضافي لمواجهه
تحديات تشاتشي بيتي في الولايات المتحده
ايضا خطبه وقائيه سجل اكثر من سته الاف
مدرس من جامعه هاربر وجامعه اخرى في موقع
جي بي تي زيرو الذي يكشف النصوص المكتوبه
باستخدام الذكاء الاصطناعي على اي حال
تقول شركه اوبنائي المطوره انها تعملوا
على النموذج الاولي لعلامات المائيه
الرقميه لتوضيح ان النص مكتوب بمساعده
الذكاء الاصطناعي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اليوم في السعوديه
نوع من القلق وهذا طبعا بلا شك ياخذنا الى
نوع من التفكير كيف فعليا يجب علينا اداره
مثل هذه التقنيات بشكل صحيح يعني في اطار
التعليميه طيب
تقنيه تشالشي بيتي تحديدا لماذا اثارت كل
هذا القلق يعني حتى الى الماسك اعتبرها
نعتق نيه ممتازه لكنها خطيره تفضل صحيح
يعني بلا شك طبعا هي التقنيه اذا ما بعرف
اذا جربتيها صيام تساليها اي سؤال ويقوم
بالاجابه ولكن الخطر انه ما لازم
نثق في المعلومات 100% لانه هذه التقنيات
التي تستخدم طبعا الريزانيج او التفكير
واي مبنيه على ما يسمى الديب وتعلم العميق
احيانا في هناك نوع من الاخطاء يعني علميه
يعني وبالتالي على سبيل المثال لو ارسلتها
من فاز في كاس العالم لا تستطيع ان تجيب
لانها طبعا دربت على بيانات قديمه قبل
2001 اختبارات
لا تنمي الكاتيل كينج او التفكير النقدي
ولكنم ايضا مهارات الاستنباط والتفكير
العقلاني ولكنها ايضا يمكن ان تستخدم
بطريقه بحيث ان الطالب هو يصبح يبحث عن
المعلومه اذا تول وسيله للتعلم وقد تكون
ايضا مناسبه لتوصيل بعض المفاهيم العامه
او الحقائق الاساسيه همم لكن ايضا هنالك
طبعا كانت تكنولوجيا اي تكنولوجيا لها
استخدامات ايضا قد تكون همم
تماما عن قطع تعليمي مع استخدامها لجهه
الاستفاده منها لكن بحدود من دون نتائج
سلبيه انا اراك دكتور في الجامعه وادرس
يعني انا اظن انه خطا انه نحذف او نلغي
الوصول الى مثل هذه لا بالعكس يجب علينا
ان نضع قطور جديد جديده تنظم اليه استخدام
مثل ويكيبيديا قبل سنوات كنا نخاف ان
الطلاب تقوم بنسخ المحتويات لكن
برايي لا نفتح هذه الجوله الجديده نجرب
المعلمين والمدرسين والمدرب الطلاب كيف
الاستخدام الامثل والامن لمثل هذه
التقنيات لاني سوف تساعد ايضا لها تطبيقات
جدا مفيده ايضا في تغيير طريقه التدريس
والتعلم
محرك البحث جوجل اليوم بدنا نتحدث عن
تقنيه الذكيه جدا بالنسبه للطلاب
ما هي ما هو مستقبل هذه التقنيات في مختلف
المجالات دكتور يعني سوف تصبح جزء من
الفريق العمل الفريق العمل الباحث وايضا
فريق العمل في همم تدريس والاعداد صفه
تغير طريقه عملنا يعني لا نضيع وقتنا في
جلب المعلومات او نضيع وقت في همم واين
نحصل على المعلومه ولكن قد تفيدنا في
اثراء وتحسين همم عملياتنا الاداريه
وعملياتنا التعلميه وايضا تساعدنا ايضا في
همم الابتكار فهي فعلا طريقه بشكل سريع
لتحليل المعلومات وايضا نقلها لكن يج
علينا طبعا ان ندرب هذه التقنيات بشكل
كبير حتى لا تعطينا معلومات خاطئه او فيها
تحيز او فيها فعليا نوع من يعني عدم الدقه
شكرا جزيلا لك انا اشتاوي شكرا لك